qui l'eu cru les jeunes raffolent des
fruits et légumes une étude vient de
démontrer que leur consommation est en
nette progression en 2003 chez les 15 35
ans il est vrai que les campagnes de
sensibilisation ont été nombreuses ces
dernières années manger des fruits et
des légumes c'est bon pour la santé
c'est bon pour le look aussi gaël
chauvin et bernie merrion suivi de
jeunes citadins cabas à la main sur un
marché
jusque sur son cabas à nord revendique
sa passion pour les fruits et légumes a
24 ans cette jeune styliste en mange à
chaque repas le choix d'une vie saine
même si ça lui demande un peu plus d pas
c'est un choix et puis même ça coûte un
petit peu plus cher et folie tiers mais
mais ça se retrouve dans l'assiette ya
une vraie différence donc ça beaucoup de
femmes qui me plaisait tant qu' avec la
canicule de l'été dernier les prix ont
flambé la consommation du légume elle
n'en a pas souffert les fruits de saison
ont toujours le même succès
la verdure a de plus en plus d'adeptes
en particulier chez les jeunes oui oui
ceux qui détestaient le concombre de la
cantine et qui pensaient que les légumes
c'est vraiment un gars ça peut être
résolument moderne que de manger des
légumes frais enfin je pense que le
problème c'est la question du temps donc
moi je ferais pas ça tous les sens mais
je le fais régulièrement une plus grande
quantité comme ça on en mange un peu
tous les genres c'est une
autre manière moderne la soupe quoi de
plus traditionnel un bol de potages quoi
de plus tendance que de le manger dans
ce bar à soupes parisien ouvert il ya
quatre ans l'établissement ne désemplit
pas le retour naturel devient une
religion c'est patrice 4 plein d'idées
plein de choses différentes on peut
envoyer terre de la carotte acidulé avec
la pomme et du jugement c'est loin
d'être un des légumes traditionnels
grâce à ses astuces les jeunes ont
augmenté leur consommation de 10% en
deux ans à moins que l'incitation
viennent d'ailleurs
de lessive
j'ai début mai manger d'être pratique
d'engranger 3 4
avec ce genre d'arguments les maraîchers
compte bien doubler la consommation
d'ici dix ans